[Music]
New Year's resolution news New Year's a
bit of a powwow
I'll do that [ __ ] pattern here's
resolution
New Year's resolution oh are you down
for the power that's all that matters
how was the gathering yes fire and smoke
to my favorite things in the world I'd
meet is that a gathering a war of like
good discussion credit oh [ __ ] I was
just hoping I wouldn't get follow-up
questions now you know how she feels
I really I know nothing she only knows
as much as the article is I can make
some [ __ ] up ask me something know
what's the powwow is it with a
discussion or is it like a gathering
it's a Native American dance
damn I believed it that's crazy yep
tobacco giant philip morris says it's
new year's resolution is to give up
cigarettes Wow
he wants to quit smoking even though I'm
not here with the company's gonna stop
selling cigarettes yeah
stop making cigarettes really not making
there they're trying to move towards not
making oh hell yeah then I could have my
chance
wait a minute I don't get this like I
get it but I don't get it so what did
they go SIL yeah weed that's money
oh we know I don't care I'll just take
over the company
I'll start selling cigarettes Philip
Morris International is the name of the
company yeah
and so they are known for making like
marble marble apologies Barbara Barbara
Barbara just borrow the marble all
cigarettes Parliament what else
yeah Parliament Chesterfield L&M Paul
I've only heard of marble Lula cuz the
branding was sick was a [ __ ] cowboy
silhouette yeah
we don't promote that we promote Donuts
yeah we got stubby Pete's causa pam
wiese have a coke mone coca-cola but
we're providing Texaco though but it's
not in the shop we took a weirdo class
anyway so they're they post it up on
their website this that is crazy that's
hing a little page it's this Plus this
Wow saying our new year's resolution
we're trying to give up cigarettes
they're going into cryptocurrency okay
just to be clear okay
that's it well I got America Philip
Morris is known for cigarettes every
year if many smokers give them up now
it's our turn our mission is to stop
selling cigarettes in the UK and it
won't be easy but we are determined to
turn our vision into reality there are
seven point six million adults in the UK
who smoke the best action they can take
is to quit smoking many will succeed but
many will continue to smoke that's why
we want to replace cigarettes with
products such as C cigarettes and heated
tobacco which are better choice for
millions of men and women in the UK who
would otherwise not stop smoking so far
we have invested 2.5 billion pounds on
research and development and has been
making a difference we've introduced new
products in many countries and millions
of adult smokers had abandoned
cigarettes and switched to better
options law
so they're going to that e-cigarette
game so just the last of it o cigarette
company has done anything like this
before you might wonder if we really
mean it we do and we're therefore making
these commitments for 2018 launched a
website and campaign to provide smokers
with information on quitting and on
alternative to cigarettes offered to
support local authority cessation
services where smoking rates are highest
seek government approval to insert
directly into our cigarette packs
information on quitting and on switching
expand the availability of new
alternative products in the UK is it a
UK company because you know what's what
it was it just tells me it's like let me
just not sell to my own people and let
me just sell to everybody else yeah cuz
even if you lose all those people the UK
Korea got you back if an American
multi-national cigarette and tobacco man
company that's a bold move you're like
we don't need your UK everybody in
America smokes so pace they also have
this foundation called the foundation
for a smoke-free world that is funded by
Philip Morris International and they
were trying to partner up with who the
World Health Organization but they
refused to partner with them and they
said quote the tobacco industry and its
front groups have misled the public
about the risks associated with other
tobacco products so that's the reason so
such misleading conduct continues today
with companies including PMI marketing
tobacco products and ways that
misleading that misleadingly suggests
that some tobacco products are less
harmful than others oh that's the reason
why who is like [ __ ] y'all you shouldn't
even be referring anything smoking so
cool reporting anything promoting
anything smoking food I think it's the
most addicting thing in a whole entire
world I think it's more addicting than
heroin I think it's more addicting than
anything I never try heroin but I did
smoke crack once and I didn't get
addicted to it but cigarettes was hard
as [ __ ] and we all that stuff it's to me
it's like easy to quit it might just be
the individual cuz some people have
their vices and whatnot but the
availability how available it is and how
psychologically addicting it is it's I
think it's worse than alcohol addiction
because it's like a slow killer like
it's not severe enough to the point
where your your your physical health is
dramatically hurt from it like it takes
a long time you know what's crazy with
alcohol for like alcoholics if you try
to quit cold-turkey you can die whatever
oh yeah again that's what's crazy yeah I
think I think up like your organs start
um filling and like you go into
withdrawal like a crazy with like
growing yourself out you have to wean
yourself it's like heroin withdrawal
symptoms the same thing you just follow
them at the mouth and absolutely
kind of think that's what happened to
Amy Winehouse cuz she was an alcoholic
yeah but then so cigarettes don't have
things like severe effects like that so
it's so subtle where people go I could
quit anytime I can keep going until it's
too late and you got lung cancer so
that's that's why it's one of those
secrets the killers cuz no one's having
this like intense 'no stats like all
[ __ ] all right
i'm having seizures and withdrawals and
I need to quit now oh yeah you know what
I mean it's just so subtle it's just
subtle and then soon and also people are
around you I don't know man there's so
many people that die over that [ __ ] but
you know what's crazy about the tobacco
industry they got into the medical
industry and they got doctors to approve
it as it's healthy and 15 in the 1950s
there used to be commercials where
doctor recommend you mean like for
pregnant lady that [ __ ] yeah I Love Lucy
some of those episodes she's smoking
while she was pregnant
danyoung and they figured out the
psychological like triggers they got it
down to a science like if you see a cool
guy in a [ __ ] movie and he's smoked
in so it's a little ass kid you have
that huh how that makes me want to smoke
right exactly when you're a little
asking all that I I watch shows and [ __ ]
I'm all like I need a [ __ ] cigarette
right now why ya know when you're little
and it's cold outside you're just like
maybe your breath in the air people
being at school yep they even add those
uh cigarette bubble gums yeah those
things
from the ice cream trucks mm-hmm anymore
okay yeah I always wondered you know
like when you work for a company is like
the whole company does that activity so
if you're in a fashion there's like that
everyone in in the companies into
fashion or if you work for a gun company
like everyone loves guns there you have
the lifestyle like I always wondered for
like the cigarette companies like let's
say Philip Morris is everyone a hardcore
smoker and everyone wants to smoke
because if they if they're not brand
ambassadors yeah like there's got to be
like people in there that know that
obviously this is bad for you
they're pretty much like they know that
they're selling poison I wonder if that
ever crosses any of those guys as Minds
is it illegal to sponsor cigarette like
no cuz I don't see that [ __ ] like like
long time ago right like don't be like
NASCAR or some yeah like they'll be
they'll have a cigarette in the camel
whatever right they have alcohol like
you get sponsor like Budweiser or
whatever on your car or what I don't see
that [ __ ] anymore because I really
wanted a red marble jacket cuz like like
Ferrari and all that [ __ ] pretty close
you know what they used to do back in
the day Michael Jackson
ah they used to have you collect like
points oh yeah I remember that my mom
would like that's what my uncle has like
traveled like duffle bags he has the
leather jacket that you're talking about
like he was like a [ __ ] ambassador
for them cuz he had so many points I
remember he stole a lot I wasn't junior
high and I used to do that like I would
collect it and put it in the bag oh my
god and you could get it in in a mail
order thing oh [ __ ] I mean cuz you know
sometimes people throw away their packs
and they don't so I could rip it off and
is on the it was called um I forgot but
yeah it was points and it was like you
get two points three points or whatever
damn what a crazy incentive to get you
to smoke I want that jacket
let me get seven more packs yeah I
remember my mom would just buy like the
whole carton of the cigarettes you just
be like oh yeah more points don't like
your mom smokes
she still do they think oh shine even
see her smoke the whole time oh she's
trying to quit she's like forever she's
been trying to quit but it's I think
smoker never completely quits like I'm
like you got it like if you were a
serious motor she's been trying to do
more of the e-cigarette stuff too but
I'm like that I should don't do nothing
it's the nicotine like no matter what if
you're addicted to the nicotine you
don't have it out of your system and
basically I've read about quitting
smoking a lot right and it the nicotine
leaves your body in like $40.00 but what
the hardest part is the habit so now
like it's like if you have this habit of
how you deal with your anxiety how you
deal with your whatever right or that's
your little meditation time and you
don't have that anymore now your body's
like alright where is it where's my
pizza and [ __ ] that's why they got fat
huh what people like quit smoking people
people yeah cuz you're orally fixed so
you're like [ __ ] I need something else
cuz you want the same amount of dopamine
so now you don't get the same amount so
you just try to do it in sugar like now
you wanna you want to over compensate
for the lack of nicotine so you're like
yeah give me more sugar give me more
caffeine and
I just have to things like flavored
toothpicks oh yeah that's it like that
world my friend used to just put a
[ __ ] pencil in his mouth cuz he would
be so fixated on doing this [ __ ] now he
has like for them he's like just do this
and you just see a chewed up pencil with
him all the time because you're talking
with smoking yeah he gave up on that
though he was he's back in smoking he's
smoking like a [ __ ] oh no I know
I've always been trying to quit for you
you know what's hard to quit [ __ ] soda
[Music]
I'm sorry pretty quick so does not that
big of a deal for me you know who got me
on that [ __ ] Bart blame you and your
[ __ ] all eyes to the top with the
Coca Cola that [ __ ] is so good I never
changed I used to be a Pepsi guy until
yeah I use me a Pepsi got to yeah extra
ice I can go the rest of my life without
shame what yeah cuz I never had that
much as a kid and I never liked it cuz I
thought it was too sweet one of the most
luxurious things you can do is when they
pour like a fresh glass of coca-cola
extra ice and you have the there's no
lid on it and you go like this and you
can see the little bubbles and it's
bouncing there here oh you're a straight
addict dude that is some bubbles dad's
it on your upper lip little tease yep
it's like there's no just kissing you
right yeah just little pegs it's like
little fleas dancing up and yeah
[Music]
[Music]